[Music]
okay everybody so
i am absolutely excited today because
i am joined by ryan simpkins aka
alice from fear street part 2 1978 which
is out
now on netflix if you haven't watched it
come back to this review i mean
interview later because we're going to
be talking spoilers
uh ryan how you doing today i'm awesome
how are you
i'm doing great so i'm really excited to
talk to you you know i was so blown away
right
performance in this film and what's
interesting i really like the character
you played of alice
and being that she's a rocker and this
is taking place
in the late 70s where did you find
particular inspiration for how you're
going to portray that character
totally um thank you for your kind
words um oh no problem i
yeah i i mean i love i love
70s music and um
the whole new wave scene but the idea of
proto-punk music i was familiar with but
i really made an effort to dive
further into so i made a massive
playlist of like early 70s punk
with like i listened to a lot of the
runaways
um some modern lovers new york dolls
um a little bit of joy division because
they just slip in there
of course of course yeah which was so
much fun but i also was like who would
alice
look up to and uh i watched a lot of
performances
of like debbie harry and joan jett to
sort of
understand her physicality like who she
would want to like
imitate and eventually like grow into as
a person which was
so much fun just like truly a blast to
be able to embody such like
[ __ ] cool ladies oh yeah and i i feel
like you got to play like the funnest
character here
opposite you know the very uptight um
cindy here so but what i love though was
that
combination of you two throughout this
film and i think it's
the core of this film and that's a
tribute to you and emily rudd's
performances but also the chemistry you
guys have together were you guys friends
before this film
and how do you build that trust with
your scene partner um
i didn't meet emily until
i got uh to set i we met
during my my makeup test um but i had
heard lovely things because i'm good
friends with olivia welch we've been
friends for years and she was like love
olivia
she's the best olivia's the best the
loveliest person um
but we are both like
super nerdy we're both like very
socially anxious people so we were able
to like
sort of understand where we were both
coming from we were like okay cool
amazing um
she's a huge anime fan i am slowly
getting into the anime world like
i've watched all of like death note and
attack on titan and i'm a
massive miyazaki fan and we would just
like hang out
i would force her to hang out with me
like every weekend
just like go get food at the mall or
whatever but
um i mean she's so lovely it was like so
easy to fall into that and she's just
like the type of person
that you feel like you can talk to about
anything like no judgment she's just
there to like listen
and hear you out and she's an amazing
person we
um one interesting thing that happened
while we were filming
is i began to realize
like alice had feelings for
cindy i was like oh it's more than just
a friendship
here there's definitely some like queer
hurt feelings and romance
and i was really grappling with that
because i was like it's not in the
script
and this is the movie without the
lesbians so i was like i don't want to
bring this up to lee because i don't
want her to be like no no that's the
other movie
and i don't want to bring this up to
emily so i just like kept it to myself
but wow with that feeling and then
like a month or two ago i finally i was
hanging out with emily and lee
and i was finally like i just alice is
gay right like this is a gay thing and
they were both like oh one hundred
percent completely
yeah and was this after the the film was
already filmed or during yeah
no this was after oh okay filming
we were this was like a few months ago
when we were we were just starting
yeah i just brought it up because i was
like okay i feel like now
is a safe time for me to confirm and
they
were both like 100 yeah we we had the
same thought
so the fact that me and emily were on
that same same wavelength without
actually discussing it with each other
was insane um it's magical in a way and
that's like the
beauty of film and art and you seeing
your character a certain way and you're
wondering
how everyone else is seeing her and how
they're seeing themselves pretty amazing
and it comes
beautifully in this film and speaking of
that relationship you have with alice do
you believe in the beginning of this
film
i mean sorry raise your hand with cindy
do you believe alice
believes cindy would one day come back
around her old self or did she kind of
give up at her at the beginning of this
film like was she done with her
i think she with hope against hope like
wanted her to come back she wanted cindy
to like be her true self
because you always when you i mean that
that's such a true thing of adolescence
like you have these friends
that you feel so close to so deeply and
then as you know people go through
puberty you just grow up they change and
that's so natural and it can be the most
heartbreaking thing but you want them so
desperately to come back like i know you
i know who you truly are
and so while she puts on this front of
like [ __ ] that [ __ ]
like i don't care about her she's fake
she's whatever
like you know deep down she's like
just waiting for the day where she turns
back to
the good side um and lets out her true
inner nature
and i think she begins to
buy the film's end but then everything
is cut a little bit short
yes which we're going to get to but
that's what i appreciate about the story
is that we get payoff and that
these things that are set up in the
beginning do get earned which i think
makes it really
good now my favorite parts with you in
this film
are the sequences with you and emily in
the cave
and it was very like to me goonies
had a baby with the descent which is
just crazy to kind of like
blend but i thought that's what made it
unique um
where are you guys what kind of set is
this are you actually like in some sort
of
tight thing like what's going on there
it was so so cool and i love that you
said goonies mixed with the descent
because i was watching
we talked about goonies a lot like in
pre-production
when prepping for this film because to
me
more than anything this feels like an
action adventure
like it feels like i feel like i'm
indiana jones i have this map
we're like exploring these tunnel
systems but it's like if
if ever if the goonies died it's like if
all of the goonies were brutally
murdered
um it's so sad
our set was amazing we built these like
huge tunnel systems um and just like
sound sage in atlanta um and it was so
cool we had like real
dirt um for like the floor everyone
around us on the crew they all had
on these like masks because at the end
of the day you would like blow your nose
and it would be black it was just like
all of this like
dirt was like being filled in our bodies
um
but it really felt like we were in these
caves you know you don't you don't
always get that in movies anymore a lot
of the times they'll just like throw up
a green screen
but for us it was like we're actually
here lost in these tunnels
which was the coolest experience and the
witch's house too was like also built
on the soundstage and i just remember
walking into set and being blown away of
like oh my god we're like
actually transported here which is such
an amazing opportunity
yeah i mean it looks just fun to be in
the movie uh
but what's really cool is like i i
really love and if i was the most
horrifying moment of the film was when
you go to touch that blob with the flies
on it
and then you're running and seeing you
know i think things alluding to the
third film
um but talk to me what are you
actually looking at here this blob what
is it you're seeing and are you seeing
those
like little girls dressed up that are
like horrifying looking or you kind of
just playing your imagination here so
the blob was so [ __ ] cool we called
it the heart of darkness
um because it was practical like in the
movie
they you know when it all came together
they added the flies and like some extra
goo and slime but it really was this
huge
fleshy rubber thing that like had a
mechanical heartbeat so it really was
happening on set
which was so cool like that's a dream
come true i love
i love practical effects so much like
the original star wars i grew up on
so that was so exciting to actually get
to like touch and feel it
and my hands were just covered with this
like sticky slime
um but i basically just when i had to be
in the trance just like zoned out i was
sort of like
okay scary scary scary scary and then
when i'm like running around
seeing those kids they weren't actually
there
for my coverage but i was shown a
picture
of like like a photograph of what the
kids would look like
with their like because they're these
like kids with these like [ __ ] up eyes
so um i sort of it was honestly
very difficult to run around in those
caves like
with a camera guy like in your following
you because you're like
you're trying not to get hurt and you're
trying not to hit the camera guy and the
camera guy's like hitting his head
on the cave wall um so it was honestly
like
i had them in mind but i was sort of
just like okay where are we going
no that shows the skill though and like
i don't think people realize how hard
certain scenes like that are especially
if you're looking at photographs you
really gotta
pull that and get in there and use that
imagination and you do so well
um and what i love though i think your
big character moment for sure
is you get a little monologue here at
the end right before
uh we lose you and you get an axe to the
face but i want to talk about what your
character alice says here where
she's talking about dad going to jail
mom's stealing so she could eat
and then around this time she started
cutting at 12.
can you just talk to me about the
mindset here of the character what she
kind of realizes by the end of this film
before she tragically
gets an axe to the face yeah um
that was such a gift because alice as a
character didn't even exist until like a
month
uh before we started filming so my
the writing of the character but also my
casting was like super
last minute um and i think lee
had this like deep love for her
and wanted to understand like how she
worked she didn't want her to just throw
in this like
fun edgy punk girl she was like who is
this person
and that monologue was added in while we
were filming
and or right before we started and it
just
made the script so much stronger to me
personally and it
so helped me understand where alice was
coming from
because she is this character who just
like exudes fun and seeks it out but i
think it comes from this place of like
she has tried to kill herself
like she gave up on life
and like seeked out death
and it didn't work so now she's sort of
like okay [ __ ] it like if i die
i die um i'm not afraid of that
so i'm going to put myself in these
situations where i can have the most fun
and feel the most adrenaline and i don't
care what the consequences are
but then through this film
she sees that affect the lives of the
people she cares about
like arnie dies tommy slater who she's
always known like she sees what that's
done to him
she sees it affect like all of these
people around her and
she almost dies you know alongside her
like ex-best friend cindy
so i think she finally realizes like no
that's not the life i
want like i do care so deeply about all
of these people and she
while in the caves and connecting again
with cindy
finds this hope like she before was so
resigned to her shitty life
in shady side and being locked in that
and not wanting anything more than that
or death
but she realizes no i can stop it and
there's this huge future ahead of me
that i can change not just for me but
for everyone around
me and that's why it's so [ __ ] tragic
that she
dies because yeah finally reaches this
moment of hope
and then she's dead and it's gone but
she does make a difference because she
find the witch's hand so it's like
hopefully yeah i mean she goes out on a
bang
and you know i i feel like alice
to me is going to be the fan favorite of
this film kind of like kate was for the
first one
and what comes with that is a tragic
ending for both of them
but you get these tweets like you know
i'm sure it's already happening as the
movie's already out but like alice
deserved better
you know so i'm wondering was alice
always going to go
out that way with the axe of the face
and was she always going to die in the
film was that from like when you read
the script was that always the plan
the plan was always just like everybody
gets murdered
we we talked that's a great question but
we talked
in our first meeting lee was like this
is the empire strikes back like
this is the one where all is lost
there's like an
inkling of hope um and because you are
introduced to all of these like
beautiful fun
characters that just die kate's death in
the first movie by the way
is so exciting and incredible and i'm so
happy that everyone is responding to it
so like with so much love
and like mourning that was maybe the
most exciting thing while we were
filming i like
saw the prosthetic that had been
shredded up
like i cannot [ __ ] wait to see this
movie
um yeah but yeah everyone the plan was
always that we would like make you fall
in love with us and then
die yeah no but it's so effective and i
think that's what
in my opinion i love about horror films
is when they can pull that off where you
love someone
you lose them but it feels more powerful
and i think it makes them go out as a
legend um
so just switching gears a bit you know
having acted
no this isn't your first rodeo here so
you were a child actor
and is is there something that comes out
like because you're around a lot of
fresh faces so like are you a little bit
of a mentor on set
and is there an advantage to that having
done this for a little bit
yeah i mean i wouldn't want to ever like
put myself
as like a mentor or like you know
a teacher or anything like that because
you're always
like a student there's always more to
learn but i was definitely one of the
more experienced people on on set as far
as the actors just because i
i have been doing it for so long um
and so i i tried to make sure i mean
there's so much going on
and when you are a young actor like you
don't
want to ever like step on anybody's toes
or like ask for too much or make things
too difficult
so on every set because i still feel
that way sometimes
but on every set i'm on i always try to
make sure that like everyone is
comfortable
everyone is like getting what they need
if they if they have
something they want to ask for whether
it's like a water
or like we're doing a stunt they're not
comfortable with like it's always so
important to check in with everyone and
be like
are you good here like how are you
feeling but i also received so much of
that from
like emily we're filming these like
horrible depressing
scenes or like screaming at each other
in a cave and she was definitely great
of being like
how are you like are you feeling okay
like we it was so nice that we had that
support system
with each other but i'm also so excited
for like
it's so many of the casts like first
big film and i'm so excited for all of
them and for me but for also like
to see them like just coming out of the
gate like that's so exciting
yeah i mean it's really cool and i like
that the way the film was casted it's
you know super diverse it's got new
faces but it's got familiar faces
i think it just attracts every type of
audience which i think is always a great
idea
um so before i let you go i did want to
ask
you've written and directed shorts
before when is the feature coming
and is that your true passion or is
acting or do you not
kind of rank them um i try not to rank
them i think the thing
about i mean i love writing i've always
adored writing and i think directing is
all sort of like
it it truly is a passion for me
but at the end of the day i just love
being on sets
um and waiting as an
actor to get the okay go ahead to be
able to like shoot a movie
can feel so frustrating and also to see
the characters that you want to see
on a set so i was like [ __ ] it i'm just
gonna do my own thing um which is where
those stories come from but i mean the
passion is definitely there
and i am i'm developing a few features
right now i just released a short
which um was really fun it's called 19
on fire and i'm
slowly working on the feature um and i
have
another feature that i'm really really
excited about
that is like a queer
horror adjacent uh vibe
that i don't want to say too much about
because i don't want anyone to steal my
idea
but i'm very excited about both of them
and i am excited for what the future
holds um
behind the camera as well so yeah yeah i
think that's really exciting for people
to hear including myself
uh can't wait to watch those and again
watch your shorts that are already out
and okay so my last question this is the
last
one before i let you go can you give us
a little tease
about what's to come this friday in part
three
will we see you again uh in any shape or
form or is this it for your character
and you don't have to even answer that
if you don't want to
it's a good question i'm trying to think
of how to phrase it
um i will say
1666 is maybe my favorite of the three
i think it's so cool and it totally
it's a totally different totally
different energy
that is so exciting and i would say of
the three movies
was the one that actually disturbed me
watching it
oh [ __ ] um and i don't know maybe
maybe a little alice will make a little
appearance
or um maybe she didn't exist yet
or maybe i don't know okay
we'll take those clues and put them
together uh no that's exciting though
and it's exciting that you love the
third film that's great to hear because
honestly
this second film blew me away and then
the whole time i'm like man how the hell
is the third film gonna top this so it's
got
it's got you know the the bar is high
now it's very high but we'll see
i'm excited to watch nonetheless
everyone watch ryan in fear street part
two 1978 out now on netflix
and obviously make sure to catch part
three this coming friday
ryan thank you so much for joining me
today i hope to talk to you in the
future
thank you so much it was nice to meet
you have a good day nice to meet you
you too